yeah welcome to a new game against um
some Norwegian flag guy we've got too
many no visa flex IAM and thus i suppose
it's got something to do with the
world's number one and maybe these guys
aren't or from norway okay so we got the
maracas see bian Tian like now o Queen B
6 and this is a ram booth doesn't have
from a great reputation the question is
though do I want Knight c3 and allow him
to take this is the only reason behind
reasoning behind us that you want to
take on c3 maybe I can just go here on
Knight f6 player three I need to cover
be too well this is why I need to react
at all and then Knight c3 next move and
then night d fibers is is a standard
issue here anyway in this position but
now it's played not a queen to see 795
is some this has gained and then
strength even I don't need to play it
instantly of course I don't think you
can take we put would be surprising care
of course it takes instantly just like
saying okay I don't care what you are
doing ok so 95 film of course if he goes
to be 5 or a 6 97 wins the exchange okay
he can go to a form and then I've got
got some options can just take is heaven
with check not too bad
can go I can also go night-night c7 it's
a also on 97 route be a tent let's say
queen 85 intending to play Bishop a7
winning the exchange I can also take on
your 7s mentioned just just grab them
okay let's let's try this i think it's
it's an interesting way you can take a
two maybe yo on this kind of approach
just move instantly it hope it's working
and it can work in blitz it's it's
sometimes just a matter of luck and not
of anything else people play instant
moves and hope they're working okay take
here you will take the night actually it
is some more interesting to try to trap
the queen is this possible maybe quincy
doing quincy to would threaten this and
yeah okay i need to move that at some
point I thought Knight to g4 would be a
good now but I overlooked something okay
okay I bet I can can do here right and
ok 1 what is he doing now if Luke sees
rook c8 is working I'll eat my head yeah
probably it is working isn't this isn't
this an unfair game sometimes okay rook
c8 he will take a one with Czechia
unbelievable absolutely unbelievable
okay can I move something else Bishop c5
are all not working amazing yeah it's
just it just funny m-maybe no regions
are unbelievably lucky and this is cards
and so guards in secret its lucky like
this guy ok now I'm trapping the look
and maybe he's got some miracle escape
again I was actually calculating this
that is not able to take at least that
this water yeah maybe he's got 94 some
yeah this is maybe even working I can't
believe it
yes he didn't plan this it's just a just
a coincidence that this is working I did
doesn't see it even yeah this would have
been good for black amazing so what is
this 4 points5 points no 6 p's got six
points right but I've got the open valve
it's not so clear rooks are are strong
pieces if they get on the 7th rank and
send stuff like that and what are you
five yeah I know it looks weird but I
want to take on e5 he shouldn't play d5
until yeah we can they can give this
jackets it's not so so terrible and just
need to make sure that you cannot play
d5
now I need to catch up a bit on the
clock this moves are maybe not perfect
but then being down on time I need to
react to that yeah I'm catching up a bit
on the clock it takes now King edge king
yum how would you see him protect this
now it doesn't so I made now on what
this would be a fun end I don't see it
what is the threat I just grab grab all
this I don't see a threat ready yeah and
why does winning in the end game now
yeah this was quite quite aquatic
chaotic game and 111 really fun issues
here I can just play 94 I'm resigning
here he stumbled into this but it he
didn't find it for some reason it's not
so difficult Nyjah for now and I can
let's just kick back a couple of moves
Moscow here and a demo and then it's
totally out totally over it if i take
here he he wins the house III and deform
i have no news so it's really amazing
that here rube c8 can be played I mean
it's just all a string of coincidences
working and while my idea here was was
obviously bad i mean this move I can
take I can take on a it's not clear
really what's what's going on just just
a position to to play ad of course yeah
as usual the computer place a the
simplest line and it's it's good and of
course I can take and this looks somehow
better for what structures just better
but that he said is even know that this
even was on some quite aha ninety five
wins who I didn't really think at this
position at all 95
yeah it's not so difficult 95 so this
here yeah this is need this isn't that
difficult really takes here take him and
now just two pieces saying he can play
something like this and continue this
stuff I mean this is the exchange it's
fairly solid stuff for black he's got
some chances to to maybe keep this
somehow um keep on playing but all in
all a very m chaotic game yeah thanks
for watching I hope you enjoyed the ups
and downs